basically going through the numbers i
think there'll be slides slides about uh
new infections hospitalizations uh and
uh deaths from covid uh and i think that
there will be a big emphasis as there
has been all this week
on uh the booster program now currently
at the moment we have about 43 of the
population uh who've got that booster
it's somewhere around 89 who have had
one jab somewhere around 81 and a half
percent uh who have had two jabs uh you
heard sanji javid the health secretary
there saying that actually people were
turning up for the first time for some
of their first uh jabs uh as well as uh
lots of people coming for their boosters
uh this week boris johnson has talked uh
about a national effort in order to rise
and raise the number of people uh with
boosters
but i suppose at the bottom line sarah j
is that we're in a we're in a bit of an
odd situation um because yesterday boris
johnson pushed through parliament in the
face of quite a lot of opposition from
his own side what i think by any measure
you had to call some pretty mild
restrictions yes there were coveted
passports which mean that you have to
show
that you're double jabbed or have a
lateral flow test that's negative if you
want to go to certain massive outdoor
venues and uh and indoor settings uh and
yes it does mean a bit more compulsory
face mask wearing and there is the
working from home garden guidance
but they are essentially
relatively
low level measures
yet the language that government
scientists are using is
much much more alarmist let me just read
you uh what dr jenny harris head of the
uk
uh health security agency said today she
said
uh that the omicron coronavirus variant
is probably the most significant threat
that we've had since the start of the
pandemic so in the last two years that
we've been enduring this health
emergency there you have one of the
government's most senior scientific and
health figures saying that this is
probably the most significant threat
that we've had now that is sounding the
alarm in the clearest possible way
yet the government response is only been
relatively muted relatively moderate yes
working from home which can make
something of a difference but that
guidance no sign of lockdowns uh no
restrictions on people meeting indoors
or outdoors uh an attempt to uh to stave
that off uh and the um controversial uh
measures that were pushed through the
house of commons yesterday in the face
of lots of tutorial position uh with the
help of labour votes uh frankly uh
relatively uh relatively mild relatively
moderate and that's because um
essentially we are waiting for the
omicron wave to hit us boris johnson has
described it uh as a tidal wave chris
whittie speaking to the cabinet
yesterday was clear uh that it's coming
uh and uh
and yet we are at the moment doing
comparatively little compared to uh some
other countries uh in order to uh try
and stem the flow now we are more there
are more boosters uh in place in the
united kingdom more people have been
boosted uh but countries like ireland
france and germany have started to shut
down bits of the economy uh things like
nightclubs
uh and uh other large uh
other large settings uh but the united
kingdom hasn't and particularly england
hasn't begun uh to go down that path uh
really at all so the question is will
boris johnson have to do that in the
coming days today it seems as if boris
joseph isn't going to do that he's
instead going to emphasize the success
of the booster program uh and also
emphasize the potential threat uh but uh
you heard sanji javid in that interview
that came in uh barely 15 minutes ago a
bit odd to have the health secretary
talking just before the prime minister
but
that's um
how they do their communications these
days is a mysterious thing
but you heard him not ruling out further
restrictions uh when pressed by the
reporter are there going to be further
changes either in guidance or in law to
how people
uh have to conduct themselves over the
next couple of weeks in the run-up to
christmas uh but uh sanji javid simply
said uh we keep these things uh under
constant uh review um and it's gonna be
interesting listening to the warnings
because if you if you look across quite
a lot of the other uh newspaper front
pages from around the world you look at
the wall street journal uh you look at
some of the german media you look at
some of the french media
the subject of omicron isn't dominating
in the way that it is in the united
kingdom uh now this is a point that's
been picked up by lots of tory mps who
are considering if at some point in the
coming days they're asked to back even
further restrictions whether or not
they'd go for it there is a singular
focus on this and a ramping up of the
rhetoric about this uh in the united
kingdom that uh a glance at the media
elsewhere in the world doesn't suggest
it's being uh it's being echoed
elsewhere so there are uh questions from
politicians about quite uh why we're
having this uh quite alarmist talk but
very many sober and serious figures in
in government are saying that we are
approaching a very big problem uh and
that action uh needs to be taken there
are some suggestions quite frankly that
there could be further restrictions
maybe they'll be introduced next week
but the government at the moment
is sticking to its guns saying that the
current package
is balanced and proportionate that's the
phrase that boris johnson
likes to use he is uh personally not a
fan of restrictions we know that he's on
the more libertarian side of the
conservative party uh but he uh uh when
pressed by scientists uh has often in
the past found it hard to resist uh some
of the things that they have asked that
they do boris johnson at the moment
really stuck between
some in his own party who resist further
restrictions further harm both to the
economy and to people's mental health by
forcing them to stay at home that's
their objection to it at a time where we
don't know whether or not um the uh
obacon variant is uh mild or serious or
the true medium-term effects of it and
the effects on
whether or not the booster program the
jab program properly provide a wall of
protection against death and serious
illness and
admission into intensive care and on the
other side you've got these uh dramatic
warnings from people like dr jenny
harry's uh calling it um as i was saying
earlier
uh probably the most significant threat
that we've had since the start of the
pandemic
so i would expect these scientists uh in
this briefing to take us through the
latest data of course today we have had
28
610 positive
cases now that's quite a high number and
that's the kind of reason that we are
getting these warnings from senior
scientific figures okay sam i just want
to bring viewers uh up to date we're
waiting for a news conference at downing
street the prime minister
will lead that news conference with
england's chief medical officer chris
whittie and nhs england's dr nikki
kanani
and they've got clearly
some interesting data
to uh show the country and uh sam coats
is with me here and sam i mean are we
expecting to see the data that chris
whitty
presented to
the cabinet yesterday
i'm sure we'll get many of the same
arguments that he made to the cabinet uh
yesterday and to be honest mark a lot of
the data is publicly available and i was
looking at it just before we went uh on
air just now and uh what that data shows
is that in the last week or so we've had
a 10 increase in hospitalizations the
figure for new infections today is uh
sharply higher than it was yesterday
that's at 20 78
610 positive cases at the same time
they're saying well of course uh testing
positive is a different lower figure
than the number of people who are being
infected today because not everybody
is being tested not everybody who is
tested as being sequenced they think
that we are looking at somewhere between
200 000 people potentially more uh
people actually being infected with just
uh a much smaller number caught by the
testing system um we are on a trajectory
the scientists say to a situation where
you could you could get without
intervention uh one million people every
couple of days maybe even every day
getting the omicron variant and then we
wait to see what happens with a
proportion of those
ending up in hospital a proportion of
those ending up in intensive care uh and
a proportion of those uh sadly dying
just at the moment uh the figures
suggest that there are 896 people in
intensive care so we've got quite a lot
fewer uh there in intensive care than
there have been at various peaks in the
pandemic um but uh the the data at the
moment is early because i mean we know
that we've only really been facing the
omicron variant as a as a national
challenge for the last what two and a
half weeks it was two and a half weeks
on that saturday night that boris
johnson popped up with chris whittie and
patrick valance just to announce uh the
first uh changes to the rules the first
uh reimposition of face masks in certain
settings like like public transport
and we also know that it takes a period
of time
for people to get infected a period of
time before symptoms kick in a period of
time before people end up in hospital
and you've got this sort of lag on the
data and that's why tory mps are going
look this isn't a great increase in the
number of hospitalizations there isn't a
great any increase still there's a drop
in the number of deaths at the moment
on the one side and on the other side
you've got the scientists go yes but
because there is this two three four
wheat lag uh in the impact of
coronavirus uh infections in the impact
particularly of omicron which is such an
unknown because it's such a new thing
you can't be complacent and just point
to today's numbers and know that we
aren't going to get a big problem
throughout christmas so so that's that
those are the issues and people are
pouring over the data from south africa
trying to delay and here we go with the
process we're going to interrupt you
yeah the prime minister's about to speak
every eligible adult in england can use
the national booking service
to get boosted now if you're over 18 and
had your second jab at least three
months ago then you can get jabbed right
now and it's absolutely vital that you
do
because the wave of omicron continues to
roll in across the whole of our united
kingdom
with over 780 000 coveted cases today
the highest ever daily
number reported and
the doubling rate of omicron in some
regions is now down to less
than two days and i'm afraid we're also
seeing the inevitable increase in
hospitalizations
up by 10 nationally week on week and up
by almost a third in london but we are
also seeing signs of hope because since
we launched our emergency omicron appeal
on sunday night a great national fight
back has begun and people have responded
with an amazing spirit of duty and
obligation to others and i want to say
that each and every one of you who rolls
up your sleeve to get jabbed
is helping this national effort and i
want to thank everyone who has come
forward whether you've had to queue
around the block at a walk-in center or
whether you've booked online
and of course on behalf of the whole
country i want to thank our nhs our gps
our pharmacists who with barely a day's
notice 48 hours notice has so
accelerated the program that we began
this week with the biggest vaccination
monday ever in england and yesterday the
biggest booster day yet with more than
650 000 boosters delivered across the
whole uk
and across the country
after all they've been through
those teams are going to keep going
through christmas and beyond
jab heroes like kim kirk leading the
king's mill hospital vaccination hub in
mansfield who was asked a year ago to do
it for four weeks
and has been doing it ever since
with 180 000 jabs and counting
dr laura mount and the team at central
and west warrington primary care network
who've been organizing pop-up
vaccination clinics for the homeless
or the team at home park in plymouth who
have been regularly jabbing until 2 a.m
because they just carry on for as long
as there are people there wanting a
booster
and
i want to thank
those from every walk of life who are
stepping forward to support them
the military personnel deployed across
every region of the country including an
additional 100 in scotland from
yesterday as well as 2 500 firefighters
and since sunday night we've seen more
than 20 000 new volunteers signing up to
help with the booster effort as stewards
taking the total number to almost 33 000
with every day we're expanding the ranks
of these healthcare auxiliaries an
emerging territorial army of the nhs in
a race against time to get those jabs in
arms and save lives and if you're
watching this
and you want to get involved
just visit the website nhs
volunteerresponders.org
dot uk
and do something this christmas
that you can tell your grandchildren
about many christmases from now
in total we've boosted more than 45
percent of all adults in england
including more than 88
of those of those aged 70 or over
and while hospital admissions are going
up nationwide we're starting to see
admissions coming down
among some of the more vulnerable older
age groups where we've already got those
boosters in arms
from tomorrow we're speeding things up
even further by removing the 15-minute
post-vaccination waiting time
and while we're at it from monday
12 to 15 year olds can book in for a
second jab and we know how crucial it is
to keep children in school so let's all
make sure our children and young people
are vaccinated before they go back next
term
as we take forward our national mission
we're of course supporting similar
efforts by the devolved administrations
which are also rapidly increasing
vaccination rates across scotland wales
and northern ireland a cobra meeting
with edinburgh cardiff and belfast is
taking place this evening
but already
the pace of rollout across the four
nations
is such that the uk as a whole now has
twice as many boosters per head as the
eu and more than twice as many as the
united states so let's keep going let's
keep
giving omicron both barrels and let's
slow its spread
and give the vaccines more time
wear face masks indoors use ventilation
get tested if you're going to an event
where you're likely to meet lots of
people and get tested if you're going to
meet elderly or vulnerable relatives
and we're helping you to get the tests
that you need i want to thank the royal
mail who are doubling home deliveries of
testing kits to 900 000 a day from
saturday
so let's
slow down omicron's spread and at the
same time let's reduce the harm omicron
can do to us by building up our vaccine
defenses we're jabbing in hospitals
we're jabbing in surgeries we're jabbing
in pharmacies and in pop-up centers
we're jabbing in shopping centers and on
high streets in football stadiums with
mass events planned at stanford bridge
and wembley this weekend and
daily jabathons at ellen road in leeds
we are throwing everything at it and
wherever you are
i will be there
with a jab for you so please
get boosted now
thank you very much i'm going to ask
chris to do the slides thank you prime
minister first slide please
i'll start off uh with slides that
people have seen before the the updates
but i think there is an important thing
to point out on this slide
which is the very high uh spike on the
very fast far right of this slide
and as the prime minister said this is a
record number of cases i'm afraid we
have to be realistic that records will
be broken a lot over the next few weeks
as the rates continue to go up
if you look at the overall rates
it looks as if delta which we've had
with us for a while is still flat
and the growth is omicron so what we've
got is two epidemics on top of one
another an existing
delta epidemic roughly flat and a
growing omicron very rapidly growing
omicron epidemic on top of it next slide
please
when it comes to hospitalizations
this really always of course reflects
where we were two
two or more weeks ago
and therefore the rates have remained
reasonably flat uh over quite a while
reflecting where we've been
with delta over the last several weeks
so rates are currently flat but they are
beginning to increase in some places
particularly in london
next slide please
and deaths of course reflect what
happened even earlier in time
and those are still if anything going
down very slightly but this of course
doesn't reflect anything in terms of
omicron because the emergence of omicron
and its spread is far too recent
next slide please
uh dr kunani is going to talk more about
the vaccination in a minute but i just
wanted to visually give a visual picture
of the speed at which the initial
rollout that's in blue
the then uh the second dose which is in
orange and now the booster rollout
is occurring
in red and as you can see it's going up
very rapidly and accelerating and that
will continue to happen over the next
period of time
next slide please
when i showed this slide at the last uh
session people said they wanted a bit
more time on it and i want to make her
two points on it
what this shows is uh what the
hospitalization
rates
uh and different age groups where in
the dark bars are people who are not
vaccinated and the orange bars are the
people who are vaccinated with two doses
first point
this provides massive amounts of
protection against hospitalization
against delta this is what we're showing
but what we're expecting to happen with
omicron
is that some of that difference is going
to be eroded
because it is less well the vaccines are
less well matched to the omicron variant
this is what the laboratory data are
implying we don't have clear clinical
data yet and therefore the point of the
booster is to try and get people back to
as good as position in terms of
replicating this really good protection
uh after they've had their booster dose
it will additionally provide protection
against delta and other variants so that
is really what we're aiming to do but
this is you know when people say do
vaccines work i really do think if
people look at these data they cannot
really argue except that vaccines are
remarkable at working but people do
still go into hospital even when they're
double vaccinated and they will still
still go into hospital
even after boosters but their risks are
much reduced next slide please
now moving on to um omicron
and uh what i'm showing here is a
screening test for micron these aren't
genotype things
this is what's called s gene target
failure but it uh now any s gene target
failure pretty well uh represents
nomicron case and the reason we're
showing this is you get these data
earlier than you get the data from the
full genotyping so it's more up-to-date
now i'd like to point out two things
with this the first of which is the
count of numbers is now going up very
fast
i'd like to point out also that the
grayed out bars those data are
incomplete and will increase
again i saw some commentary that said ah
that shows it's going away uh next time
uh the last bits of data and the same is
true in the uk it's also true
incidentally in south africa the last
bits of data will always increase as new
data comes in
uh but both the numbers but also the
percentage of cases is steadily rising
so an increasing percentage of all of
our cases is now omicron but that's not
because delta's going away it's because
omicron's being built on top of that
uh next slide please
the final slide i wanted to show um is
really just to show that this is
happening across the whole of england it
is also uh happening very clearly in
scotland
and beginning to happen in wales in
northern ireland but these these are
data from england
in london now the majority of cases
uh in london are going to be omicron
and therefore that is going to be where
we will be from the time we get to
probably christmas onwards i would
expect most cases going to hospital to
start to be omicron cases
i would like to make one final point
before i hand on over to dr kanani which
is i think that there's been a certain
amount of uh commentary
about the fact that um doctors and
scientists from south africa and i
really want to pay huge tributes to
south african science and medicine what
they've done so quickly has been
remarkable
have uh indicated that there may be some
reduction
in the hospitalization rates they're
seeing
with omicron and i want to put a really
serious caution on this because i think
it has been over interpreted
the first caution on this is simply a
numerical one
if the rate of hospitalization were to
halve but you're doubling every two days
in two days you're back to where you
were before you actually had the
hospitalization if the peak of this is
twice as great then halving of the more
so the hospitalization rate you still
end up in the same place and this peak
is going very fast
but the second point i wanted to make
which i'm not sure has fully been
absorbed by everybody
is that the amount of immunity in south
africa for this wave
because of a prior delta wave and
vaccination is far higher than it was
for their last wave
and therefore the fact that there is a
lower hospitalization rate is
unsurprising
so if you think about what happened to
us in the uk
with our alpha wave in uh january
february this year
uh the host the infection
hospitalization rate for people over 65
was around 22
prior to vaccination
once you have a lot of immunity due to
primarily vaccination and then also some
natural infection the infection
hospitalization rate in the same age
group has dropped to six percent that's
just because there's more immunity
well there is more immunity in south
africa now than there was in their last
wave therefore some degree of drop is to
be expected now we that doesn't mean
that there isn't
some degree of
slightly milder disease that is possible
but i just think there's a danger people
have over interpreted this to say this
is not a problem and what are we
worrying about i want to be clear i'm
afraid this is going to be a problem
exact proportions of it of course south
african scientists and uk scientists and
scientists globally are trying to
determine at the moment i'd like to just
pass on for the last slide to dr
khannani nikki
nikki thank you very much thank you very
much
um so there is clearly one single
challenge that our country faces right
now but we have two asks of you as a
member of the public
one is please come forward and get your
booster and if you're unvaccinated come
forward and get your first dose or if
you're severely immunosuppressed get
your third dose your vaccine is there
and it's waiting for you
and our second ask is please help your
incredible nhs team
come and work with us as a volunteer or
a paid member because we need your help
since the prime minister and our chief
exec commander pritchard set out the
call to the nation the national mission
around vaccination we've seen an
incredible response and it's the sort of
response we've seen all through the
pandemic and through the first part of
the vaccination program
people have come forward again and again
to help us but to get protected as well
and as i've been around the country
visiting vaccination sites i have seen
cues around the block but people have
been incredibly kind and thoughtful and
patient looking after our nhs teams
while they wait to get protected
our nhs teams have done an incredible
job
day on day we are now seeing
record-breaking numbers yesterday we saw
an incredible amount of vaccinations
delivered by community pharmacy alone
absolutely through the through the roof
and they're doing a fantastic job
but you need to do your part
from today you're able to book an
appointment online to get your
vaccination if you're over the age of
18. you go to the national booking
system and you can book a time and date
that suits you near to where you live or
if you're traveling you could book
somewhere near to the work that you have
to do if you're an essential worker
because we're making it more convenient
than ever to get protected
we've already vaccinated over 20 million
people with their booster doses that's
over half of eligible 18 and overs and
three quarters of eligible 50 pluses
that's a huge number and today when we
open the national booking service to
everybody who's eligible over 18 we had
over 500 000 so that's over half a
million bookings by the time i left the
office to come over here
so i know that everybody wants to play
their part
so thank you for coming forward when
you're asked to thank you for booking
now that you're able to
my thanks of course need to go to our
nhs and voluntary teams who once again
are pulling out all the stops i know
that you're tired i know that this feels
hard but i also know that you can do it
i've heard from countless people around
the country saying we want to help you
we want to help the programme we want to
respond to the mission because fighting
omicron is the most important thing that
we can do
but i want to reassure you that while
our gp teams who have been delivering
the lion's share of vaccinations will be
vaccinating more again they will also
protect urgent and life-saving care
alongside cancer care
so be patient with your nhs and with
your general practice teams because
they're trying to do everything to
protect you as quickly as possible
as the prime minister said our teams are
getting out into the community just like
at the beginning of the programme we are
going door to door to look after the
house bound we are asking the severely
immunosuppressed to get
protected as quickly as possible with
their booster if they've already had
their first three doses we're asking
teachers to come forward during the
school holidays to get protected before
school starts again
we have got pop-ups we've got mobile
units we're working with community and
faith leaders to make sure that
everybody has the opportunity to get
this protection so please come forward
and as the prime minister said we have
lots of opportunities to help i know of
many people many of my friends who i'm
incredibly proud of who are busy as it
is who are saying i want to come forward
and i want to help at vaccination sites
around the country and any little that
you can do will help us to deliver this
enormous ask
our team are working as quickly as
possible to get volunteers onto the
front line
and i just want to make sure that you
know that you can all play your part
get tested when you're asked to and
follow the government guidelines make
sure that you focus on getting your
booster if you haven't already and if
you're able to come forward and join
this fight against omicron
because i promise you if you can come
and help us our nhs will be here for you
thank you
thank you very very much nikki and thank
you for everything that you and your
teams are doing it's absolutely amazing
can we go now to questions from the
public teresa from starbridge
i'll read teresa's question if initial
steps to prevent the spread of omicron
in the community have failed why is the
government rolling back on contact
self-fire station for omicron confirmed
cases instead of making self-isolation
more widespread uh for all covered cases
uh to further
slow the spread of all variants so i
think what you're asking there uh
teresa is is why are we going for the uh
the daily uh contact uh testing uh insta
instead of
uh the uh the self-isolation period of
ten days that's because we think we can
get uh the same uh result and we think
we can do that without generating what
everybody remembers from uh earlier on
this year uh the ping demick and the the
reason why i think that's a good idea
teresa is because as we go into this uh
particularly uh tough time here at the
nhs and many other organizations uh we
we want to keep supply chains uh running
we need to keep things uh moving and a
ping dem it would really make uh things
much more difficult so we think we can
uh we can we can tackle it uh in that
way and we think that's appropriate and
anything you want to do well the only
thing i just wanted to add uh prime
minister was just to re re-emphasize
this is we're talking here about
contacts
if people have got uh covered if they've
got symptoms we would want people to
self-isolate but those people are
have a high risk of transmitting this is
an incredibly transmissible virus
correct thank you very much uh teresa
addie from uh nottinghamshire
uh with the spread of uh omicron
increasing what is your plan for the
clinically vulnerable do you plan on
putting shielding back in effect i think
i'm going to hand that straight over to
to you chris and nikki if you want to
comment
thank you president the uh the the
what we've decided is that at this point
shielding came with some very serious
downsides for the people involved in the
shielding
uh including loneliness and mental
health issues practical problems so it's
not an area what we want to go down if
there's any way of avoiding doing so but
there is a lot of things we need to be
doing for the clinic of vulnerable and
they include for people immunosuppressed
uh i think as most hopefully most people
who are in that situation know that they
should get three doses of vaccine as
their primary course
and then subsequently
they should get a booster on top of that
so they should have four doses in
comparison to the rest of the population
having three
and there will also for example be
things we'll be wanting to look at in
terms of antiviral drugs and how we best
can use them in this group of people who
are particularly high risk i don't know
whether nikki you want to add anything
to that that's fine thank you thanks
good thanks very much let's go to laura
koonsburg bbc news
um
thank you very much premise there um as
you said there have been more cases
today than there ever have been
if now isn't the time for extra
restrictions when we'll be and to both
of the medics can i ask you really
straightforwardly do you think it would
be better if there were now more
restrictions immediately and should the
public cut back on their christmas plans
thanks for laura and i'll have a go at
that first and let me let me explain
what we're what we're trying to do i
think this is the uh the right approach
it's a a a double uh strategy it's a
left and a right for uh for omicron uh
we're we're going with with plan b
as we said we would uh in the event of
of the numbers starting to rise uh and
in the event of a new variant appearing
and that's that's the right thing to do
and everybody i you you'll have heard me
repeat earlier on uh what we need people
to do to use ventilation to wear masks
inside continue to to wash your hands
exercise uh caution uh
uh to to
uh do daily contact testing and and and
so forth if you come into contact with
somebody uh who has uh omicron to
isolate certainly if you if you have
omicron uh
uh to get tested when you want to go to
a a nightclub or another
venue all those all those restrictions
uh are coming in and that's the right
thing uh to do to to slow the the spread
of the of the disease but what we're
also doing is using a tool that we
didn't have laura if you think about it
a year ago uh when we were also facing a
spike and that is the huge advantage uh
not just of testing but also a
vaccination and the booster the booster
does uh provide all the evidence seems
to be the booster does provide
a an excellent level of protection
and
uh
we think that given the the balance of
risks and the balance of continuing um
uncertainties about omicron this is the
right approach to take the right mixture
uh
of approaches that to do these two
things at once and
the progress that we're making with the
booster is absolutely vital these
numbers are extraordinary uh for the
british population i mean we we really
are boosting a huge numbers of people
now uh we've got a much higher
proportion of our population boosters as
i said at the outset either than the
united states all in the rest of
europe i think over 90 percent of the 75
to 79 year olds uh have been boosted now
and that's terrific because it's those
groups don't forget that uh sadly
provide the the bulk of the uh of those
who are likely to to to die uh from kobe
so by getting boosted now uh we can
really build up our wall of protection
whilst we slow down uh the spread of the
of the disease with plan b so it's a
it's a two-pronged uh a two-pronged
effort
my answer would be i mean ministers
clearly have to choose two really
unpalatable options but what we do not
have at the moment is clear data on some
of the really key questions and the two
that i think are the most important
uh are what is the hospitalization of
severe disease and in due course
mortality rate with two doses which we
are right the way through the population
of existing vaccines and what are we
looking at with a booster on top
remembering we've now got the great
majority people over over 65 boosted and
that rate is going up those data will
come in there's some very early
indications from lab studies but they're
not really strong enough to be able to
make strong clinical recommendations and
obviously ministers will take a lot of
account of new information as it comes
in in terms of your your second bit of
your question uh i mean
i think that what most people are doing
is and i would think this seems very
sensible it's prioritizing the social
interactions they that really matter to
them
and to protect those ones
de-prioritizing ones that matter much
less to them and i think that's going to
become increasingly important as we for
example go into the christmas period and
people are also taking a lot of
precautions and i think it's exactly
right so that for example uh if they're
going to visit a group of people or if
they're visiting vulnerable people
they're taking tests beforehand i would
strongly encourage that and strongly
encourage sensible things like really
good ventilation meeting outdoors if
that's appropriate and easy
and all the things we know that we've
done uh systematically through this so i
just think a lot of this is people
following sensible rules but
prioritizing the things that really
matter to them and de-prioritizing the
others
i mean all i would add is that my
patients
have had very mixed experiences through
previous lockdowns and some have been
incredibly isolated and their mental
health has really deteriorated so
everything that we can do as a public
as individuals to reduce the burden of
the disease to get our boosters and to
make those choices that chris describes
is right i mean
i want to see my immediate family on
christmas day so i'm going to be really
really careful until i get to that
moment and not just testing but watching
what i do and prioritizing working on
the vaccine program working in general
practice and so that i can get those
special moments with my family and i
know that that's what everyone will
choose to do if they can because that's
our best way through along with getting
booked for their booster
thanks very much robert peston itv
um with the best one in the world the
surge in boosting
is not going to kick in for three or
four weeks but now is the moment when
people are going to parties they're
going to the pub why aren't you more
explicitly
discouraging them from doing that
um dr kennedy you
said
that
your colleagues
are working incredibly hard they're
exhausted for 18 months they've been
putting their lives at risk if i could
ask you and professor witty
how did you and they feel when you saw
those photos of officials in downing
street and conservative central office
having parties
when they were risking their lives and
the rest of us were locked down and
finally prime minister um
would you welcome a police investigation
of the parties that took place
here sorry i'm gonna ask the uh
chris you want to go first
i mean i don't have a huge amount to add
to what uh
i said previously which is i do think
people should prioritize what matters
and that by definition means
de-prioritize other things and i think
people are doing that and i i think i
would recommend that and i think most
people would recommend i don't think you
need a medical degree to realize that is
a sensible thing to do with an
incredibly infectious virus about which
there are quite a lot of key things uh
we don't know
and then in terms of uh uh other areas i
mean yes i mean i think it's it's a
statement of fact that when people think
uh there's unfairness and particularly
if they think there's unfairness uh uh
in high places of course people get
angry uh i'm not commenting on
individual cases or commenting on the
rights wrongs of anything to be honest i
never have throughout this and i don't
intend to start now but what i do think
is most people actually
separate that out from their absolute
need
to think seriously about what's good for
them their communities their families
their workplaces uh and uh the wider
country and people i think really are uh
taking that very seriously and i don't
think those two are in conflict i think
people basically can do uh both
simultaneously
i think what i would add is that our
staff
as i said have been working for a really
long time both through the pandemic and
to deliver this incredible vaccination
program and i think they'll keep going
um you know whatever else happens um
nationally in other places we're here to
look after our patients and our public
and that's what drives me every day um
you know no matter what else is going on
and that's what my teams and my
colleagues will continue to focus on
and i just say to you robert that i
think you completely mischaracterized
the events in this place where people
to
the best of my knowledge have worked
blindingly hard for a very long time
in cooperation with people around
government and across the whole of the
public services to do our very best to
keep people
safe but we'll of course hear from the
the cabinet secretary about uh about
what he uh believes has happened uh and
indeed and if the police think there's
anything to uh to to to follow up i'm
sure that they uh that they will but i
think that if i may say so i think that
the public can readily as i think uh
colleagues have said the public can
readily distinguish between uh these
types of reports and these types of
accounts and the overwhelming imperative
uh that we have now together to tackle
this disease in the in the uh the two uh
pronged way uh that we are and i think
those are the the messages that i'm uh
seeing the the public understand very
very loud and clear and and really
responding magnificently with the uh
with the way people are uh you said it
you know it'll take two or three weeks
for the uh for the vaccine rollout to
get going that's not my impression uh
it's it's the immunity to build up well
i think that's a that's a actually i
think that that is a moot point because
i think that uh the uh
i mean i'd like to hear from uh from uh
nikki and chris on that i believe that
uh with the booster you start to get at
least some uh immunity perhaps a bit
quicker than you you've suggested but
perhaps that would be well i think the
general point is a very reasonable one
actually the timing yes i would expect
some protection probably even beginning
within a week
and quite a bit within two so it's a bit
quicker but your general point which is
of course there's gonna be a delay is a
fair one it's just probably slightly
less than
uh you're implying nikki
yep uh i mean um all we can do is move
as fast as we can so we can get people
protected and and that's why the other
um points um chris and pm have already
made are right you know we follow the
guidance that's there and work from home
if you can we need those trains as empty
as possible so essential workers can go
in safely um wear your mask as much as
you can and
look after each other that's that's what
we're here to do
thanks so tom newton done the times
professor whitney uh question for you
jenny harris today said the on the crown
vote was the most significant threat to
public health we've seen during the
pandemic
grand medley there's you know chairs
uh spyen has called it a very real
possibility of the nhs being overwhelmed
do you agree with those two statements
and may i also ask you just to give us a
little bit more detail on what you said
were studies on severity and mortality
so they weren't complete yet but can you
share with us what you know so far on
that um prime minister question few i
want to bring up the vote last night
sorry about that but it is relevant to
this whole discussion
now a lot of your mps say it wasn't just
about coping parties it was about you it
was about your leadership and they want
you to change they want you to run a
better operation about an upper ten and
stop putting the car into the ditch to
use your words will you change and if so
how
so on the first one and uh echoing a
point that um nikki made uh this is a
really serious threat at the moment the
how big a threat there are several
things we don't know
but all the things that we do know are
bad and the principal one being the
speed of which this is moving it is
moving at an absolutely phenomenal pace
and therefore between the time that it
first starts to really take off in a way
people will be able to see
and the point when uh we get to very
very very large numbers will be quite a
short one and that i think is part of
the issue uh in trying to deal with this
so i i certainly echo the fact that this
is a very serious threat i think to
compare it to each of the very major
threats we've faced i think it's quite
difficult because as the prime minister
said that we do have some things
going for us this time of which the most
important is the existence of effective
vaccines and the ability to boost at
speed at this stage so i think but i
think i do not wish to underestimate
this and for my nhs colleagues in
primary secondary care
i am afraid there will be an increasing
number of omicron patients going into
the nhs going into hospital going into
intensive care
and the exact ratios we don't yet know
but that there will be substantial
numbers and that that will begin to
become apparent in my view uh fairly
soon after christmas it'll start before
then but in terms of the big numbers i
think that's a reasonably i'm afraid a
reasonably nailed on prospect
uh in terms of the what i was trying to
explain on the severity and it is a
relatively subtle point but i wanted to
make it because i think it's been
misunderstood
there are broadly two ways that a a
virus
like this could be less severe uh if
someone's caught it one of which is it's
intrinsically less severe it's just as a
milder virus and there are milder and
more severe viruses ranging from ones
with 100 mortality rabies for example
all the way down to ones with
essentially zero percent mortality so
you could have a move on that but the
other way in which is much more common
actually where something becomes more
severe is because we have more immunity
and the point i was making in south
africa
they between the last wave and this wave
their degree of immunity has
substantially increased
and therefore there is much greater
south african immunity to covet in
general
not specific to omacron than there was
in the last wave so some decrease in
severity you would expect because of
some protection from uh increasing
immunity
in contrast for our delta wave we
already had incredibly good immunity due
to the amazing job the nhs has done in
double vaccinating everybody
so we don't have that
additional thing on top so it may be
that some of the some of possibly even
all of any inc decreased severity from
south africa is it just explained by
immunity and if that's the case that's
not something you would necessarily
replicate here the second thing is from
south african data incidentally of
course is that their age groups are very
different there are a number of other
very major factors hiv a whole branch of
other things so reading across data i
think needs to be done with very strong
care or mortality
so we do have hospitalization data from
south africa the rates and
hospitalizations in south africa are now
going up relatively fast on mortality we
do not yet have data and that's because
this is so
so recent and of course as everybody
knows there's a lag to getting
infections allowed to getting symptoms
allowed to uh getting to hospital and
then a lag to a minority of people dying
and that time frame has not happened so
we don't yet have data or mortality and
obviously as soon as we do we will share
it with the public
yeah and uh tom just on your uh your
point about about parliament look i i do
understand the people's uh feelings of
principle about uh what they see as in
infringements on liberty and
we've been trying throughout this
pandemic uh to keep society keep our
lives as as open and as free as possible
and that's the aim of uh of what we're
doing indeed the the aim of of plan b
plus the get boosted now campaign is to
is to is to ensure that we are next year
uh is as free and as open as possible
that we protect our uh our society and
our economy in every way that we can um
i have to say i don't think that the
measures that were proposing or that
were parliament enacted uh for
nightclubs and some other settings like
uh football matches in any way amount to
a vaccine passport because after all uh
all you've got to do you know you've
just got to get a lateral uh flow test
or if you have a proof of vaccination
then you can get in it's it's entirely
optional so i i don't i don't uh follow
that line uh of argument uh but you know
i just want to say i'm i'm grateful that
parliament uh voted it through a
majority of uh of a large large majority
of uh of conservative votes uh went to
to get this done and it will help us to
keep the country on track i think if we
can
do these two things at once uh implement
plan b in the way that we're describing
plus uh get everybody boosted at record
record speed
in the way that we are uh we'll be able
to move forward and and keep on the on
the path that we have begun to travel
and that is made possible uh because of
the incredible efforts of the of the nhs
and and the british public and and those
are the people i really i really want to
thank i realized i realized i said you
were from the times in fact you're from
times radio
will you change it wasn't about the vote
last night they want you to change i'm
certainly not going to check thank you
very much tom i'm certainly i'm
certainly not going to
change the policies that have led to the
fastest uh vaccine rollout in europe the
fastest booster uh campaign uh in uh in
in europe now and and delivered uh 500
000 more people in jobs uh now than
there were uh before the pandemic began
and that's uh those are the things which
i would respectfully uh suggest that uh
the public uh uh you know also also keen
uh to focus on steve swinford of the
times
um professor whitty in scotland nicholas
sturgeon is advising people to limit
household mixing over christmas is that
something that you think families should
be thinking about as we approach
christmas to limit the number of other
households that they interact with over
the christmas period in their own homes
and prime minister the last time you
held a press conference you were saying
that people should go ahead as normal
with christmas parties now we've just
heard professor whitley say we should be
de-prioritizing less important social
events so do you think that people
should still be going ahead with
christmas parties or is it time to
cancel christmas parties and furthermore
about new year what do you think about
new year should people be planning big
social events at new year or should they
be limiting those now
chris i i'm probably going to start
record on this i really think people
should be prioritizing those things and
only those things that really matter to
them
because otherwise the risk of someone
getting infected at something that
doesn't really matter to them
and then not being able to do the things
that do that matter to them
uh obviously goes up i i don't i don't
think you do you need to be the doctor
to think that i think that's what most
people are very sensibly calculating and
that seems to me a sensible approach
personally
yeah so
that's the whole point about what at the
point i'm making is don't mix with
people you don't have to for either work
or uh for your the sort of family things
that really matter to you i would be my
general advice to people in this kind of
situation but uh people have to make
their own choices
yeah thanks uh steve
i agree totally with chris about uh the
the the response but that we're already
seeing from
everybody our general instinct uh to be
more cautious uh but i i said many times
that i thought that this christmas will
be considerably better than last
christmas and i i stick to that uh we're
not canceling uh events we're not
closing hospitality we're not cancelling
uh people's parties or their ability to
uh to mix what we are saying is you know
think carefully before you go uh what
kind of an event is it are you likely to
meet people who are vulnerable are you
going to meet loads of people you you
haven't met before uh and and uh get a
test and i think that is very very good
get make sure that there's ventilation
uh wear a mask on uh on on transport uh
and get a test before you go so
it's
we're in a different environment thanks
to the the boosters uh from from where
we were last year but we've got to be
cautious and think about it uh whilst we
wait for the for the benefits of of the
boosters uh really to to kick in
thank you a mesa hall the express thank
you prime minister um
i could ask the medical experts i mean
it's becoming clear that we're going to
need to keep having boosters to keep
topping up our protection against uh
coronavirus
what's your best guess for how often
we're going to need to do it is it going
to be every six months every three
months and is there a case for a
national permanent national vaccine
service to to the nearby boosters and um
prime ministers if i could just pick up
pick you up on the um you talked about
keeping supply chains moving earlier
obviously a lot of people there's gonna
be a lot of work absence as people
become infected and have to take time
off work are you concerned at all that
emergency services essential industries
may come under pressure and what steps
are you doing to
cope with that
thanks uh
should i take the first bit
nikki and then i'll say supply chains i
i think it's not yet clear how often we
will need to do boosters essentially
there are two separate reasons to need
to do a booster the first one is that
the immunity was good
is still good but is waning so that's a
matter of topping it up from time to
time
and then the second one is as we got
with omicron something comes in field
left that actually the vaccines work
less effectively against and you need to
do something to actually top it up to
actually get on back to where you were
before
the new variant came in
now on the first of those we don't yet
know
how long the immunity will take to wayne
in general i think most most people who
look at this would say that after a
booster the waning may be a bit slower
than it was after the second vaccine but
we don't know that and so we need to see
those data and make decisions on that
and of course immunity is quite
complicated it's made of several
different elements it's not not just
antibodies it's a variety of other ones
but of course whenever we do get a new
variant for the moment we have to ask
the question does this new need a new
vaccine as is being asked at the moment
now in the long run
my expectation is and
the long run doesn't mean many years but
maybe
not this year in the long run
we would expect uh that we'll get what's
called polyvalent vaccines where you
have multiple different
forms of the virus in the same vaccine
and the reason that's important is it
makes it a lot harder for the virus to
evolve around that at the moment we've
simply got a single uh thing based on
the original strain
once we've got those i think new
variants that can do as much change as
omicron will probably become rarer still
may happen from time to time and but we
do now have technologies that mean we
can move them very quickly
that's a long answer but i think it's
something that a lot of people asked so
i thought it was probably worth laying
that out uh dr konani may want to
comment on the second bit yes thank you
thank you i mean it's something that we
are obviously thinking about how do we
get the right vaccine infrastructure um
prior to the pandemic which feels so
long ago we did have a vaccine
infrastructure it was our general
practice and community pharmacy teams
that would vaccinate
children it was our school teams that go
in and vaccinate in schools and
obviously our annual flu vaccination so
we're used to having to do things
annually and psychically but we are
definitely in a different position now
and we can't keep using sort of big
venues every time
so we are putting that infrastructure in
place and we are asking officers who've
seen our community pharmacy colleagues
to step up but we're also seeing that
other venues are offering their services
um not just now but into the longer term
as well so as we learn what we need to
do to respond to this variant we'll
build the infrastructure in the
background so that once we know the sort
of uh pattern that we're going to have
to respond to we'll have that
infrastructure in place
and mesa to your point about about
supply chains we're going to throw
everything at it to try to to sort it
out in actually some of the the issues
that we saw earlier uh in the autumn
started to to get better like the hgv uh
driver driver shortage uh but we are
gonna make sure that we do everything we
can recruiting a huge numbers of people
for instance for the nhs trying to help
care the care sector so vital that we
get the the staff there daily contact
testing rather than self-isolation i
think will help i'm not going to pretend
this is going to going to be necessarily
as smooth as everybody would want but
we've got to get through it and
you know repeat the key message the best
thing everybody can do is get boosted
now get the booster faster as you can
and the the the higher our wall of
protection andy woodcock independent
um if i could ask the uh medical experts
you've suggested that people will be
prioritizing family get-togethers on
christmas day itself um this year i
think a lot of people out there will be
thinking that situation you have
multiple generations coming together
from multiple households in close
quarters quite possibly very little
ventilation particularly if it's a cold
day i think people want reassurance is
it really advisable for that sort of
event to go ahead it's and could i ask
all three of you um
are you planning to what are your plans
for christmas day itself and are those
being scaled back
and um to the prime minister um since
the reports of various parties that um
damaged it or alleged parties at downing
street
um there have been polls suggesting a
fairly sharp fall in public trust in
politicians generally and yourself uh
personally
uh kyocerma today said that you didn't
have the trust and authority to lead the
country through this crisis i was
wondering
while the
questions about uh alleged law breaking
are still unresolved at downing street
that is do you are you still confident
that you are the right person to be
giving instructions and guidance to
other people in a way that will maximize
public compliance
thank you um
chris and nikki on on christmas
i didn't say what people would be doing
they some people prioritize christmas
day and some people prior to other
things what i was saying is people
should prioritize what matters to them
and usually that is family that
different people from different
traditions will take different
approaches
um in terms of uh but christmas is
clearly the majority uh at this time of
year in terms of um what you know i i
realistically i think there's a high
chance that my original christmas plans
with family are going to be interrupted
uh i hope it's not completely but we
shall see and i also am very realistic
about the fact that in advance of the
situation where large numbers of people
enter a hospital
very large numbers of people in society
and that includes doctors nurses and
other healthcare workers are going to
get covid
at the same time because this will be a
very sharp peak
and there will be significant problems
on
of people uh actually providing staff to
man and to generally you know be able to
look after
any part of
the health and social care system and so
people like me should keep some degree
of flexibility to actually deal with the
fact that actually we may end up with
quite substantial gaps in rotors at
short notice and i just think that is
unfortunately given what my and this is
back to nicky's point given how much
difficulty my
health and social care colleagues have
had over the last two weeks two years
saying that is pretty depressing because
they have really really had to stand up
and go back again and again but
uh the reality is this
speed of an onset is going to lead to
lots of people getting ill
simultaneously and we have to be
realistic about that
thank you um
andy this is our chance to make choices
for each other and for our nhs so um my
advice would be if you're going to go to
a stadium at the weekend make it one
where you can get your vaccine um or
help out to give a vaccine rather than
you know going to going to watch a match
and to that point if you're a role model
in society please get your vaccine
because actually it's dependent on all
of us to show the way right now and to
make decisions that help to protect
society um as for my christmas christmas
plans are already scaling back um you
know there will be far fewer things that
i'll do with my children as we run up to
christmas and if they're listening sorry
but that is absolutely a fact but we
will enjoy it together and we'll enjoy
it at home and we will enjoy it safely
and as and when i need to work over the
christmas period i will be just as my
colleagues will be because that's what
we're here to do so um
everyone just get book your booster now
because that is our best way to protect
our nhs and to protect the people who
are giving all of their time and energy
to look after our public
yeah and he asked for my own christmas
plans i think the way things are uh
looking i expect a lot of us are going
to be working
throughout the uh the period my own
plans as you can imagine a pretty uh
pretty modest at this stage uh
but i just on your point about rules i
look i think everybody i follow the
rules everybody across politics uh
across politics should follow uh the
rules but what i notice actually is that
the
uh the british public
in response to uh what i said what we
said on on sunday have really got the
point
uh that this wave is coming in
uh that there are two things that we
need to do
that we need to implement plan b
that's now
going ahead but everybody also needs to
be uh getting vaccinated getting the
booster and that's the i i think the
numbers are extraordinary uh people are
queuing around the block across uh the
country uh in in towns and cities across
uh the uk and every day we're adding
more and more people more and more
volunteers 33 000 are now coming forward
another 20 000 people coming forward uh
to uh to help get jabs in arms and
you know that message is unquestionably
getting through to people it is a
fantastic thing it's absolutely vital
that people hear it loud and clear so
i'm going to repeat it get boosted now
thank you all very much thank you
well there we are that's the prime
minister
confirming first of all that uh there is
a new record number of cases in the last
24 hours uh also a 10 increase in
hospitalizations he said uh in the last
week
but he said they've boosted more than 45
percent of all adults in england more
than 650 000 booster jabs given
yesterday but the chief medical officer
chris witte warned that omicron was a
really serious threat a number of
records will be broken in the coming
weeks he said because we have two
epidemics running at the same time
hospitalization rates are beginning to
increase he said in some places there is
going to be a problem he said
substantial numbers will get ill
simultaneously
he also said that he urged caution about
reports of a
drop in hospitalizations in south africa
and he said vaccines are less well
matched to omicron and that is why he
said it is so important for people
to get the booster jab
it's uh just coming up to six o'clock
let's bring in our deputy political
editor
sam coates and sam i suppose the big
question from that is will the booster
campaign be enough or will other
guidance or measures be necessary quite
soon in short what sort of christmases
you know are we going to have
well mark boris johnson insists that he
has uh the right approach that was his
phrase but watching that press
conference it was like watching two
different events almost that in parallel
you had the much more cautious much more
downbeat
uh interventions from chris ritty the
chief medical officer and nikki kanani
the medical director of nhs england um
and then a
slightly more boosterish approach from
boris johnson so to take you through the
key messages from chris witte because i
think it was chris whittie who was the
star of today's show um he said as you
mentioned that we have to be realistic
records are going to be broken not
records in a good way these are records
and the number of um
infections potentially hospitalizations
possibly deaths we are waiting to find
out what those uh what the data is on
the impact of the booster program and uh
uh and the jab program on omicron but
chris whittie currently worrying that
records uh will be broken because you've
got these two epidemics and he was
talking there about delta which was uh
until a couple of weeks ago the
predominant variant in the united
kingdom and then omicron which has
rapidly caught up pushing up those
numbers to record numbers
of cases today chris whittie also said
that there will be big numbers fairly
soon going into hospital
after christmas he said that prediction
for him was reasonably nailed on um and
then he made a plea not uh for all of
those people looking at social media uh
seeing just the first signs that omicron
might not be as severe it is certainly
transmissible more transmissible than
any other uh variant but it might not
result in in particularly severe illness
if it does uh if it does take hold he
said there are several things about
omicron we don't know but the things
that we do know are bad and he issued an
enormous very clear health warning that
the data coming out of south africa
suggesting it's mild may not be
applicable uh in the united kingdom
simply because of the different
circumstances uh the different timings
the different waves and the different
types of immunity in that population he
said that the figures from south africa
suggesting that omicron was milder have
been over interpreted
and suggested that the lower
hospitalization rates were a result of
the big delta wave that they had
not long ago
and then you've got the question that
you touched on mark which is the one of
restrictions now you watched nikki
kanani from nhs england and you watched
chris whitty trying not to deviate from
the government line but frankly the
message was a bit different uh to that
of boris johnson so chris whittie said
please prioritize the social activities
that matter to you don't mix with people
that you don't have to be there at work
or at home in other words you don't much
like your colleagues don't go to that
christmas party
don't go to the social events at home
perhaps with people that you aren't
great friends with in other words reduce
the amount of social contact that you're
having nikki kanani talks very
personally she said this
you know this christmas she's going to
do less they're going to see less people
she apologized to her own children
for saying that and said if you're going
to go to a stadium go there to get a
vaccine rather than
see a match and there are lots of people
with tickets to to games this weekend
how will they be
left feeling after that warning from
nikki kanani but in the face of that
boris johnson's tone was a bit different
uh he said yes it's right to be cautious
but then he re-emphasized we're not
closing hospitality we're not cancelling
parties we're in a different environment
thanks to last year the guidance remains
the same which is that you can go and do
all of these things boris johnson is
embracing a world in which individuals
act with greater caution
but is also trying to make clear to the
public he's not in the business of
cancelling everything so it's up to you
not up to there uh
not up to him couple of consequences of
that first of all well what about
hospitality the hospitality industry up
and down the country the prime minister
uh leaning slightly into people being
cautious that's going to be devastating
in terms of their bookings over the next
weeks and months no sign particularly of
any help from the treasury to help uh to
assist with that and secondly people
will be saying if there aren't
restrictions why can't i go ahead
and do this in some cases that guidance
is
somewhat grayery or getting different
tones from different figures
what is the public to make of that
okay sam thank you very much indeed and
joining me now is dr david nabarro
special envoy on covert 19 for the world
health organization and chair of global
health at imperial college london thank
you david for being with us so
i think we start with well so